[Music]
hello there it's been a while fortnite
chapter 3 turned all our expectations on
their head and with season 2 kicking off
in a matter of days it's now a perfect
time for a season recap going over
everything story related over the last
three months so sit your butt down for
10 minutes slapping creator code adamaru
to support videos like this and let's
revisit the season
during the final days of chapter 2 a
fight between the imagined order and the
last reality reached its climax while
loopers like you and i fought off the
cube queen's forces above ground the
iowa were underground preparing to
evacuate this gave us a plot twist and
the return of the seven the foundation
the scientist and the visitor all showed
up to rescue the loopers as well as
agent jones the man who knows about a
dude named jenno you came back for me
you promised me geno who will be
important to the future of fortnite
foundation and jones switched off the
gyroscope holding the island in place
and then the entire island flipped over
proving fortnite is indeed a flat earth
kind of planet it's weird but also great
after drifting around in the ocean we
made it to the new island
[Music]
week one the season officially began
with a monologue from the foundation
himself telling us our drive and what's
gonna power us through the season it was
super simple help the seven free the
zero point and defeat the imagined order
in the first few days we were recruited
by the scientists you know the guy from
season x season x is here he gave us
this it's basically a mobile phone he
used it to call us about 30 times over
the season the scientist was in charge
of restocking the seven ready for the
next battle with the imagined order and
to do this he needed to collect tech
which was stuck in space and attempted
to launch a rocket but was unsuccessful
this was due to signal jammers placed
around the island but we took care of
them the new island somehow felt
familiar and looked like chapter one the
placement of the volcano the lake and
other biomes felt the same yet different
to compound these thoughts we found the
arm of the mech from season 9 chapter 1
a detached limb resting in the water
exactly where it landed all those years
ago these similarities would grow each
week wait is that tilted towers the
daily bugle was somehow brought onto the
island likely in a similar way the
scientists created rift beacons in
chapter one this was never confirmed but
how else would part of spider-man's
world be stuck in a crumbling volcano we
received a little jonesy law on our
first few days on the new island the
looped versions of the blonde ding dong
had set up their own society and wrote a
declaration of independence
stating they won't fight for any side
anymore they count themselves out of the
war between io and the seven and to
really top off the law of this first
week a secret audio log could be found
in which the scientist is trying to
coerce the paradigm into rejoining the
seven we haven't heard from her since
chapter one and the scientist is
starting to sound a little desperate
paradigm uh it's me i'm i'm guessing you
heard what happened like i know our
history is complicated
but i want you to know
i never lost faith in you
so we really do not deserve your help
right now not at all but
we need it and a few days later she
pinged back she's listening somewhere
out there
when week three arrived the community
was in christmas spirit and things
became more criminal related snowmen
decorations the cabin returned we all
opened gifts like a sentinel from the
matrix movies but there was a few things
story related behind all this rumbling
could be felt underfoot the scientists
sent us to play seismometers around the
island why was the island shaking like
this the results were the thick guy but
he didn't let us know instead on
christmas eve he unveiled a new rocket
just like those we saw in chapter one
and the scientist sent that bad boy up
into space of course that happened off
camera so here is my highly skilled
recreation
[Music]
weak force are a huge change in the
fortnite story the woman we last saw
interrogating agent jones has reappeared
the io led by dr sloan have made it to
the new top site using drills to break
through many of us were a little too
busy watching the new year celebrations
to notice but all the time io were
formulating their own plan meanwhile the
scientist was still trying to convince
the paradigm to return it was getting a
little bit embarrassing we have reports
of seismological disturbances from the
underside of the island that leads me to
believe that the imagined order are not
only active they're gathering forces the
imagined order is playing with a fire
that will consume every world we know
and every world we've yet to discover so
hurry home
while we still have one
i think that means things are getting
serious
[Music]
week five arrived the snow began to melt
and christmas decorations were removed
including at crackshot's cabin which was
now boarded up for another year in the
south a second io drill made it to the
surface io's offensive was taking shape
slowly as more personnel joined sloane
on the new top side oh and the rocket
the scientists sent into space last week
yeah well it failed but that does not
stop the scientist
so our first rocket recon mission failed
but you know what they say
when one launch pad door closes another
one opens so we helped him build another
one
week six into the new chapter and we
received the weather update it was
mind-blowing to see a tornado build up
and rip through the island taking random
objects on a road trip and not to
mention those storm clouds with thunder
and lightning electrifying the ground
below it may not have added much to the
story but damn it was a good update oh
and another io drill appeared today
that's three now two more to go
[Music]
it suddenly happened the frozen version
of tilted towers we all watched thor for
seven weeks was finally free of the snow
and ice a near perfect recreation of the
original poi from four years ago from
the no sweat insurance building to the
diorama inside telling of the story of
chapter one and the funny thing is this
version of tilted is exactly in the same
place as the chapter one version of
tilted which once again confirms this
new chapter is the original island it
appears that during the end black hole
event the island was flipped without us
knowing and now thanks to the foundation
it's been flipped back again this update
also brought us clumbos they serve no
purpose at all but just look at that
face so bloody cute we all found out
that colombos are immortal and get angry
when shot this update had more to offer
we also saw the arrival of haven and her
mask collection along with a small poi
for her to call her own but this was
where something really weird happened an
excavation site appeared out of nowhere
archaeologists had found the skeleton of
a mythical beast upon closer inspection
it was confirmed to be the devourer the
remains of the polar peak monster who
tried to break into the zero point in
2019 before being reduced to bones by
singularity coincidentally that's the
person who i and many others believe is
the paradigm and the paradigm of course
is set to come back to the island soon
oh and the scientists second attempt to
get a rocket into space jetted off this
week
it's week nine and a monumental update
hits the island a brand new pli popped
up straight into the mountain face io's
covert cavern arose this is a stronghold
for io operatives as they plan the war
against the seven armed to the teeth and
brimming with loot most of which can be
found in their secret vault covert
cavern is protected by gunner a thick io
agent who was last seen having his face
smashed into a control panel he's now on
the island and ready to fight thanks to
a few upgrades around culvert cavern are
secret areas referencing another
fortnight season chapter 2 season 2 to
be precise and the midas operatives for
some reason they all have belongings and
memorabilia everywhere making many of us
think midas will return soon io has not
stopped there another drill site popped
up and yet more io troops infested this
side of the island they could now be
found in vehicles roaming the roads
collecting intel and taking out rogue
loopers io are far more prepared for the
next battle than the seventh this was
also when the foundation became
unlockable in game the day your entire
lobby was filled with duane's
and one more thing the tire glitch was
discovered in week nine throwing these
things at items could heat them across
the map things which were immovable
could suddenly be moved even the
foundation statue best glitch ever this
week the scientists had us taking out io
operatives to find out how their funky
black suits worked and to maybe create a
version for us to get inside aisle
facilities unseen
week 10 arrived and the scientists let
us know some more bad news the second
rocket we helped to put together yeah it
failed again but this time the scientist
knows who is to blame so the rocket it
failed again the imagined order
sabotaged us and i'd like to know how
disassemble their tech and bring the
pieces to me i'll reverse engineer
solution i'm like super smart the
imagined order have deliberately stopped
the seven from rebuilding and preparing
for their next attack every single time
we sent a rocket into the void of space
sloan and her gang found a way to shut
it down this has prompted the seven to
be more aggressive and the loopers were
sent to smash up iotec which we did
because we are team players and this
week the fifth and final io drill hit
the surface of the island the imagined
order massively outnumber the seven at
this point
[Music]
week 11 saw a change in the fragile
standoff between io and the seven
because the scientists built another
rocket that's three rockets this season
two fails but this one will work we hope
as we prepared to launch something
strange happened at the io cavern a
strange rumble could be felt underfoot
that became an earthquake and nearby
trees and rocks and roads began to crack
and break the io were drilling underfoot
and slowly started traveling south these
drills are going to change the face of
the island
the following week the secret drilling
struck something we all love the
greatest drop spot on the island was
ruined the diner became a sinkhole to be
honest the service was lousy there good
riddance the drilling immediately
started up again but this time it moved
east
week 13 and it happened again a new
sinkhole appeared this time taking out
this lovely home what a shame and once
again when a sinkhole appears the isle
drills seems to change direction this
time it began to go north this week saw
an easter egg added out of respect for
the tyre glitch a month earlier stacks
of tyres are placed by the foundation
statue to remind us that glitches are
the greatest thing in video game history
it's a shame they get patched on the
horizon it was possible to see the moon
had changed into a heart the pink light
would streak across the island it was
pretty cool for those dumb men who don't
know why the moon is like that this week
i'll help you out tuesday the 8th of
march was the day all women were born
aka international women's day you're
welcome later that week the scientists
told us to destroy those pesky i o
drills that have been ruining the island
and things got even better because the
paradigm finally got back in touch with
the scientists well she didn't actually
say anything i'll let him explain
paradigm has accessed her navigational
accounts and appears to be preparing for
a long journey so the way i see it
either paradigm has had enough and is
going as far away from the scientists as
she can or she's coming to the island
like really soon
[Music]
we're in the last fortnight of this
fortnight season and the drilling
underfoot remains the main focus of the
loopers a few days later it was official
the first act of war between the two io
removing a seven building for the first
time cutting communications to this part
of the island the reality war is coming
very soon
which leads me to today the final week
of fortnite chapter three season one we
know io is ready to battle and we know
the paradigm is on the way back to back
up the seven we've seen the polar peak
monsters remains being dug up and we've
seen three rockets sent into space we
now have confirmation the third rocket
was successful rocket launch 3 was a
success i did it
with your help it only took 15 weeks to
do it gigi's everyone as this week and
this season comes to an end we'll assist
the scientist one last time as the
paradigm makes her long-awaited return
right now the island is littered with
underground rumblings and drilling can
be felt everywhere the island is about
to change forever and the reality war
between io and the seven is only days
away i'll let the scientists have the
last word on this
paradigm
it's me again
uh this is my final message
everything and i mean everything depends
on you now we've always been so much
more than just our pilot
in our darkest days
you brought us hope
you brought us together and after
everything you've been through
i wish we didn't need you to suit up
again
but we do we really do
all reality is yours to save you know
that's it just all reality
you just need to come home
i'll see you in season two here's a
bunch of legends who've used my code see
you next time
[Music]
you